allah - la d6 là
n1 guitare dans mon main - les devant un
tas de bonnes que mikko n'est pas moi la
chaux montmagny transpire dans un grand
silence dans la salle
mon coeur qui bat vite il ya c'est hier
bat vite à l'amont les à l'arrivée
insiste au vent vient écouter
insiste au vent
ont l'air l'arrivée
[Musique]
tu connais camarade tu connais qui 5000
et tu connais camara
tu connais kossa i vé
s'il a pas moins saura et note normal ap
ap fait fausse note
l'apal ok 1 à mette ensemble nous toutes
nos va arriver s'il a pas moins saura
normal montlhéry vient faut me décale
ma
on continue le combat
[Musique]
les deux
md
je ne
ii p
[Musique]
après mon dernier l'accord des sourires
plein regard communicatif encourageants
mais rappelle encore comme s'ils étaient
hier c'était mon premier fois ci la
scène le soir du 21 mai 2010 en
australie une appel idriss mon nom de
scène ccaf marron et il fait maintenant
sept ans que me parcourt le monde en
chantant avec la langue créole dans mon
coeur
en cadeau mon long may you ali comme un
singularité un richesse un l'ouverture
qui mène au partage et à l'échangé
quand opportun par deux ou même que
l'autre n'a point forcément nous
ressentent plus riches mais que ça zot y
pense quand midi le mot créole les
antilles la réunion
est ce que nous faisons
petit sondage un instant à main levée
qui pensent que nana plus de 10 langues
créoles dans le monde
à main levée au caire est vrai ça demain
comme ça qu'ils pensent 20 30 langues
créoles non 50 quand même
et ben en réalité n'est la 57 langues
créoles et ça à travers le monde entier
répandu sur tous les continents
mon bouche la red bull un grand roux
bergos mal à prendre ça na le créole
australien parlée par plus de 30 mille
personne n'a le créole en papouasie
nouvelle guinée
mettez connaît même pas la télé si
l'accord les parlers par 2 millions de
personne n'a le créole au nigeria parler
par 65 millions de personnes et nous
peut continuer comme ça na na 57
exemples comme ça au départ la langue
créole c'est juste un code un système
des changes pour facilite les rapports
entre deux mondes qui ne connaît pas hot
chacun ne l'a dû faire un effort faire
un pas vers lot avec son band mot
apporte son savoir-faire son kilt chine
et puis prendre un bout de sa flotte
aussi et c'est ça que me m dans la
langue créole c'est que lee fait le lien
en deux mots nous lie c'est le trait
d'union entre les cultures et malgré
tout
les souffrances que nous l'a pu
traverser la créolité il continue fait
son chemin et il continuera samba nous
grâce à la créolité voilà à prendre un
tas d'affaires grâce à mon identité
plurielle mme 11 ans est blanc noah mais
inscrits en moins dans l universalité
on a foi en l'humain et tout ce qui
rassemble à nous me rappelle encore
quand il était petit mois l'a fait mon
catéchisme à la partie l'église
et puis en sortant maman papa t emmène à
moins d'un temple indien temple tamoul
me rappelle encore noté fait carême
pendant sept jours
parfois même plus me rappelle encore
parce que dément pas la viande
et puis plus loin dans notre quartier
nous ça va service kabaré malgache mal à
apprendre bien plus tard que dans toutes
les cultures créoles à travers le monde
entier
les femmes y pratiquer deux à trois
religions en même temps un genre de
laïcité 2.06 me appelle ça comme ça
rassure azote mois les pas pratiquants
mais ça pas converti personne mais tout
ça juste vous dis qu'avec la créolité
voile apprendre le respect des croyances
des religions de chacun et quand ils
voient les conflits dans le monde
le terrorisme la migration forcée mais
forcément mimi comprends pas avec
lang kréol voilà rend compte le maloya
un musique d' influence africaine
européenne indienne malgache chanté en
créole et ça me trouve ça joli mais
trouve ça magnifique ça y fait vivre -
avec zot i pé deux autres affaires
miro sans que le monde litres an dans
son bonne souffrance dans la méfiance
dans la peur de lot et moi me dit il
faut notre en mairie
il faut nous vivre avec lui il faut nous
vivre avec lui avec notre langue de
notre guerre en cadeau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
créole - c'est la vie et apprendre à
vivre ensemble créole c'est la vie
ensemble créole c'est le respect c'est
un potentiel de paix exemplaire tout le
monde entier créole sait où c'est moins
c'est nous tout c'est pas seulement
n'être c'est devenir créole c'est rouv
zot caire à la différence parce que déjà
chaque différence emma la richesse
[Musique]
non
ce
à nous n'a la sagesse
pour nous tout en vrai à l'apu danse et
syna la guerre dans un ghetto amène nous
va s'enrayer
demont
soleil fait plus haut de mon la ligne
pour la marine
vous vous tomba
à nos enfants
ats
ma
la racine gravi dans ton pot
faut pas les slogans oublier nina irone
itil est faux mais depuis mois les mémes
un film trouver des mires ensemble faut
nous tiens bouffe automne le caire
trieux cris yes
[Musique]
à nous enfants
ats
[Musique]
c'est aussi
de 10 ans deux enfants t elle
sang de la terre tout simplement
vidaza chante avec moi
les 13 ans
[Musique]
enfants
as tu es là
[Musique]
azote
ats
si tu veux la paix
viens
a t elle
il y a
à
[Musique]
enfants
à 2
dans ton pays n'a la guerre
viens
ats
il y a
à
[Musique]
un déni fois à nos enfants
tu es là
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]